[Music]
invision in the Scarlet Witch volume 2
number 3 scarlet and division found out
it was impossible for human and an
Android to conceive so Scarlet Witch had
her very own marvel Immaculate
Conception she's magic to make herself
pregnant and gave birth to twin boys
myself the vision had his memory wiped
he and scarlet got a divorce and the
twins turned out to be shards of the
demon Mephisto the Avengers and x-men
decided she was too dangerous to live
and in an act of self-preservation in
house of M Scarlet Witch created a new
reality where mutants were the majority
and magneto was the ruler but this too
backfired and Scarlet Witch was forced
to take action
whispering the words what's next for
scarlet
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Doctor Strange
two-in-one division video we have some
really cool marble phase for Easter eggs
so we'll break it down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for Doctor Strange
to on the video so we have Scarlet Witch
herself Elizabeth Olsen explaining some
of the classic comic book stories
they're going to cover during one
division in Doctor Strange to some of
those I know make you really excited
there's some other stories that she also
talks about that they hit during the
previous Avengers movies that I'll
explain in then there's another big
Marvel phase for Doctor Strange - Easter
Egg that was just spotted on the set of
one of the new Disney Plus series Marvel
revealed last year that Doctor Strange -
is going to crossover with Wan division
because Scarlet Witch is going to be one
of the main characters of Doctor Strange
- so one division is kind of like a
prequel for Doctor Strange - so a lot of
these Easter eggs are related to both
the movie and the Disney Plus series
just going down the list starting with
number 5 in that video elizabeth Olsen
covers a ton of Scarlet Witch Avengers
Marvel Comics stories the new ones
they'll be covering between one division
and Doctor Strange to start with the
classic vision and Scarlet Witch
miniseries that just revolves around
their romantic relationship in the birth
of their twins Wiccan in speed we saw
them in the wand division trailer not
the actual babies themselves on screen
you just see as they move through the
decades of different sitcom tropes she
gets super pregnant by the time they get
to the 1970s Brady Bunch looking version
of their house and then by the time they
get to the 1980s Family Ties looking
version of their house the twins have
been born they're in their bassinets
they're levitating pacifiers vision is
wearing jeans in flannel which is
hilarious he looks exactly like Tom
King's version of vision from his run
which is also a story they're gonna be
adapting for the one division series but
this is just to let you know that the
twins have powers on their own first big
real x-men Easter egg in the Wanda
vision trailer that we've seen aside
from her actual comic book costume
number for the next big comic book story
she explains is the white vision
Avengers story that's what they're
referencing with this black and white
looking vision in all the 1950s looking
scenes meant to be a parody of the Donna
Reed show remember after Avengers
infinity war everyone was like how come
they didn't bring
vision back during avengers endgame
Shuri made this big deal about trying to
repair him and separate him from the
mine stone during infinity war wouldn't
she be smart enough to repair him the
reason why they didn't do that is
because they're waiting for this big wan
division twist they knew they were gonna
do this and they were gonna adapt a
version of the white vision story from
the comics as elizabeth Olsen explains
in that video the white vision was a
version that they brought back from the
dead
but they didn't give him the same mental
framework from a real human so he came
back with no personality at all he was
just really cold and unfeeling like a
true robot the Avengers speculated
during infinity war what would happen is
they tried to separate vision from the
mine stone that's all probably just the
lead-in for these white vision black and
white TV looking scenes it's also a joke
about how characters from the 1950s
didn't have as much personality as
characters from the present-day
there's a lot of comedic aspects during
one division in a lot of the tropes that
they're calling out but during that
white Vision story as Elizabeth Olsen
says they reveal the scarlet witch's
children were really just soul shards of
Mephisto and so this is where we get
into Mephisto stuff because everyone's
wondering when he's gonna show up
between Doctor Strange - in the Wanda
vision series you can actually see some
different Mephisto comic book panels
from different Marvel Comics behind this
producer here she's actually the
showrunner for the Wanda vision series
just implying that there will be some
Mephisto stuff going on during it like
this one here actually seems like it's
from spider-man one more day and if
you've read that just post all your
Dormammu I've come to bargain Mephisto
memes the theory here though is that
Scarlet Witch during the Wan division
series learns that she's in an alternate
reality or a false reality and her
children aren't real but tries to find a
way to keep them and bring them back to
the main MCU universe so if it wasn't
clear both Wan division in Doctor
Strange - our multiverse stories that's
why a lot of these Mephisto and a lot of
these comic books Scarlet Witch Easter
eggs are all related to what's going on
during Doctor Strange - then obviously
number three even bigger multiverse
story the big house of M comic book
story that she explains mostly a lead-in
for one of the ways the MCU is starting
or will start to reference more mutants
in the comics as she says she creates an
alternate reality in the Wanda vision
series it's implied she's in an
alternate reality so it's a safe bet
that that twist with her children
carrying over in
- the main MCU universe will be their
big house of em Easter Egg the other
even bigger x-men Easter Egg there the
no more mutants house of M twist I think
/ all these other Easter eggs will be
more of a reverse no more mutant
situation in the comics it was all about
her getting rid of mutants but in the
wand division series in Doctor Strange -
it seems like they're implying she'll be
responsible for even more mutants
showing up it's also really cool to hear
her speak those words out loud
whispering the words those powers sort
of get into the idea of her chaos magic
Kevin Feige hyped up that they would be
going full-blown comic books Scarlet
Witch during the wand division series in
Doctor Strange - so it just sounds like
they're going to be doing a lot of that
stuff then number 2 bringing it back
around - Mephisto there have been rumors
that he'll be referenced somewhere
between Wanda vision and Doctor Strange
- in some way whether or not he actually
appears remains to be seen there been
rumors about Evan Peters playing a
villain during one division we'll see if
that winds up being true but it just
makes sense that they would try to
invoke him in some way because he has so
much comic book history with Scarlet
Witch her children which are featured
during the series and separately with
Doctor Strange recently someone spotted
another big Mephisto Easter egg on one
of the other Disney plus series if you
can believe it this is actually from a
falcon in Winter Soldier seen what would
he be doing in Falcon and Winter Soldier
it doesn't have anything to do with
supernatural stuff as far as we know
this is a biker gang that they encounter
with very Mephisto looking devil heads
on their jackets the scene is taking
place in Matt rapport which is a
location from the x-men comics so even
more x-men Easter eggs during Marvel
phase four this biker gang might not
have anything to do with the actual
Mephisto but it's just another reminder
that he exists in the MCU the way they
seed Easter eggs in all kinds of
different movies in series because
number one big callback there was also a
major Avengers Mephisto scene from the
first Avengers movie a long time ago
that most people missed when it first
aired in theaters Marvel has since
downplayed it but when Nick Fury is
coming to visit Captain America to
recruit him for the Avengers
he hands in this big file that has a
huge Mephisto Easter egg in it
hydras secret weapon
so you rewind you watch that scene again
you zoom and enhance on this page here
you see direct reference to Mephisto and
the infinity gems on the same page when
talking about the tesseract in the
Infinity stones so early on this gives
you an idea for what Marvel was planning
initially for the Infinity Saga Thanos
assembling the Infinity Gauntlet
it sounds like they originally had big
plans to include Mephisto because
Mephisto was working with Thanos in a
really big way during the comic book fan
oohs Infinity Gauntlet saga later what
Marvel did though is they sort of erased
some of these references and changed
some of the wording so it sounds like
behind the scenes they ranch some rights
issues with the character and they
wanted to use them in a bigger way than
they were actually able to so they had
to sort of retcon some details later on
in the version of infinity war and
avengers endgame that we saw in theaters
didn't really reference Mephisto at all
there were a lot of other early x-men
Easter eggs that they tried to weave
into the Marvel phase 1 movies all the
way up into the first Avengers movie but
I think they ran into issues with Fox
and then separately with Sony trying to
include all the spider-man stuff and all
the x-men stuff and they just weren't
able to clear it with those different
companies at the time you have to
remember that Mephisto actually debuted
in the Silver Surfer comics which
technically gives Fox some rights to the
character and then Sony separately had
used the Mephisto character in the Ghost
Rider movies with Nicolas Cage so the
rights to that character which is kind
of a mess but now that isn't an issue
now that they bought the Fox characters
they have all the x-men rights back they
can use them anytime they want in one
division in Doctor Strange 2 are just
the next big major dark supernatural
related stories that they have coming up
but everyone let me know in the comments
how do you want them to use Mephisto in
the MCU if he winds up being a big
multiverse level villain this is a big
Virtual Comic Con 2020 event happening
later this summer I'm assuming that
Marvel is going to start dropping a
couple of its big trailers around then -
like the full wand division trailer full
Falcon and Winter Soldier trailer and
maybe a Marvel Eternals trailer -
whatever ends up happening I will do
videos for everything so no worries as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them every one click here
for my new spider-man into the
spider-verse
- in spider-man ps4 trailer video and
click here for my brand new Wonder Woman
1984 trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe
see you guys tonight
[Music]